[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht's ein super leckeres rezept
wie immer halt
heute gibt es gulasch wir waren gestern
mit murat in calw und da waren wir im
brauhaus und haben damit eine richtig
leckere gulaschsuppe gegessen denn
wirklich gut
und jetzt haben wir gedacht die müssen
heute sofort nachmachen und das ist
jetzt kein spezielles kulas also es gibt
ja wirklich viele gute rezepte auch
ungarisches gulasch und am ende ist im
prinzip egal was erfunden hat hauptsache
es schmeckt ja und effekt wollen sie die
schweizer die scheibe habt ja hauptsache
es schmeckt
wir machen ist ein rindergulasch und ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für das
rindergulasch brauch ich vier esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl 60 18 800 gramm zwiebeln
ein kilo rindfleisch das sage ich gleich
was dazu eine chilischote nach belieben
habe ich noch vier große patrick haben
vier esslöffel tomatenmark etwas
fleischbrühe und ein paar gewürze und
zwar zwei bis drei esslöffel
paprikapulver etwas rosmarin und oregano
majoran wird auch gehen zwei
lorbeerblätter 700 gramm kartoffeln
diesem festkochend und salz und pfeffer
aus purer spaß natürlich perfekt in die
kalte jahreszeit etwas von innen wärmt
und schmeckt einfach immer gut genau und
ich wünsche euch freuen dich wenn die
auf eine skifreizeit geben oder so ist
dann machen die über 420 personen leonie
gulaschkanone und vor allem ist halt
toll wir machen das jetzt
ich brate es jetzt hier an und stellt
dann in den backofen dann darf das
wirklich zwei drei stunden einfach
schmoren und dann wird es richtig schön
zart und weich und man kann ihn derzeit
etwas ganz anderes vorbereiten
es scheint auch ein super rezept zum
vorbereiten also erst einmal das fleisch
es ist ein kilo und zwar hat der muss
mir in fleisch aus der keule mitgebracht
und durch taktisches bürgermeister stöhr
und zwar dann sieht es bürgermeister
steht gleich überall weil das haben
früher die metzgereien und die
schlachtereien haben das immer für den
bürgermeister auch gemacht
wegen des bürgermeisters stück man kann
sich auch andere fleisch china
du kannst auch aus der warte zum
beispiel nehmen hauptsache das ist eben
nicht zu trocken ist also zum beispiel
wird ein richtiges cola
wobei da kann es auch mit viel machen
schneller als mit halt schnell des
schaltest aber richtig soll so schön
durchwachsen sein
ich hätte es vielleicht in kleine stücke
schneiden so etwa 1 5 bis zwei
zentimeter unterschied ob die steuer
extrem volkswährung das kino war
unwirklich für school aus braucht man
kann natürlich aber sind durchwachsen
das stück viel besser
[Musik]
zum anbraten nehme ich jetzt einen
schmortopf sind habe ich jetzt schon
aufgeheizt und den ich jetzt weil ich
davon super gut anbraten kann und den
aber auch später in den backofen stellen
kann deswegen erst ein echt super da
muss man nur aufpassen welcher komplett
aus gusseisen da verteilt sich die hitze
natürlich auch sehr gut er speichert
auch die hitze aber er wird sehr heiß
das heißt hier außen nicht anfassen am
besten in ein handtuch oder einfach so
in schutz
wenn wir euch nicht verbrennt jetzt
nehme ich ein bisschen öl 3 und berater
das fleisch an mehreren stationen an
also jetzt nicht ein kilo fleisch
komplett in den topf geben weil da
einfach dann die größe des topfes nicht
reicht
[Musik]
so entstehen im topf wird natürlich
richtig tolle röstaromen und das gleis
nämlich dann fraktions weise einfach
wieder heraus
[Musik]
kleines beispiel dreht kann ich schon
mal die zwiebelwürfel und sie werden
jetzt fein gewürfelt und ebenso auch die
knoblauch sehen
jetzt macht ihr das entweder mit einem
messer oder zum beispiel mit dem
alligator
[Musik]
das leise sitzt angebrachten jetzt gebe
ich das restliche öl hier rein und
schaltete ein bisschen runter damit die
zwiebeln jetzt nicht verbrennen
es werden die zwiebeln etwa 56 minuten
glasig angebraten und deshalb kann ich
schon mal die paprika bögen und die
werde ich jetzt aber ein bisschen grob
würfeln distel und größere würfel dann
nämlich einfach diese scheibe und das
sind etwa ein zentimeter große würfel
[Musik]
zu den zwiebeln kommt jetzt noch das
tomatenmark kurz angebraten
und gleich danach kommen jetzt auch die
paprika würfel mit rein wir ruhig dann
auch noch einmal durch
es kommen noch die gewürze mit dazu und
wer setzt so richtig scharf möchte mit
dem ziel das paprikapulver oder sogar
cayennepfeffer und das ganze lässt sich
dann mit der fleischbrühe ab und wer
möchte kann auch zum beispiel rotwein
nehmen
schalte ich den herd aus
geht da noch das fleisch mit dazu
jetzt alles mal gut durch
[Musik]
und dann ist jetzt einfach mal gucken
bei mir waren es etwa 400 milliliter
fleischbrühe muss einfach so viel sein
dass das fleisch gut bedeckt ist halt
gut bedeckt den später kommen ja noch
die kartoffel mit dazu liegt sehen ja
auch so ein bisschen feuchtigkeit
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf und dann
geht's ab in den ofen
dem ofen habe ich jetzt schon mal auf
160 grad ober unterhitze vorgeheizt da
stelle ich bin schmerzfrei und dann wird
es gulasch etwa zwei bis drei stunden
eher geschmort und eine stunde bevor es
fertig ist also nach zwei stunden bis
die kartoffeln natur bieten
[Musik]
sie habe zumal die kartoffeln geschält
das habe ich jetzt gemacht
ich kann mir noch ein bisschen länger
stehen lassen sind sie ganz weg die haut
jetzt nehme ich das da dürfte die
topflappen nicht vergessen
durch wir sehen jetzt auch gleich ganz
viel flüssigkeit mit drin ist perfekt
für die kartoffeln
das riecht ganz wunderbar ich werde
jetzt gleich mit salzen und pfeffern
aber wer vorher die kartoffel noch in
stücke schneiden
jetzt macht ihr einfach die größe so wie
er es gerne haben möchte wenn ich sie
jetzt groß habt dann sind wir später
noch ein bisschen bissfest und einfach
ein bisschen fett statt ich habe sie
ganz gerne wenn sie fast schon weich und
matschig werden deswegen schneide ich
sie jetzt in etwa 2 cm große würfel
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich an der stelle schon mal
salzen und pfeffern und da könnte jetzt
ordentlich sei es auch noch mit das so
geben und auch gut mal abschmecken
wenn es dann nicht versalzen es ist
perfekt denn die kartoffeln sagen ja
auch nochmals ein bisschen auf
und jetzt kommen die kartoffeln mit rein
jetzt ruhig es nochmal gut durch und
gibt es dann noch mal für eine stunde in
den backofen und kühlschrank
[Musik]
bereits als ich jetzt zu hause riecht
schon richtig gut es ist grad kurz vor
14 uhr alle hunger aber alle auch die
kamera bilder ganz so wie ihr seht ich
habe immer noch genügend flüssigkeit
wurde sie zur richtig lecker aus bonn
ist richtig uhr also ich bin bereit ich
bin ich weiß nicht genau was er so drauf
jedenfalls können sie das jetzt so
servieren satte 260 grad und damit auch
richtig hübsch mich sagte dazu weil er
moratti sonst verbrennt und jetzt gebe
ich jetzt immer kleine völkchen rein die
sind auch aus gusseisen mit den kammern
auch packen das heißt ihr könnt im
prinzip auch darin dass wunsch zu
bereiten aber ich finde jetzt gerade zum
servieren richtig richtig cool finden
bis wir sind richtige ein clip schon vor
der staffel jetzt doch schon jetzt meine
idee
ich habe ihm nämlich freunden erzähle
unten gulasch reinmacht und oben drauf
weil sie sich eigentlich und deckel zum
warmhalten zb oder zum überbacken und
man kann obendrauf das aber auch so rum
benutzen und dann zum beispiel ein
kartoffelgratin machen sei unheimlich
okay was klug gemacht was auf den deckel
genommen macht noch mal drauf
richtig oder falsch falsch von suchen.de
sofort würde ich jetzt hier noch einen
teig rein machen welches komplett im
backofen reingeben und da dann ist so
ein kleines brötchen backen überraschend
leicht ist brötchen und ich glaube ich
mach mal so ein menü und halten so
fleisch oder gemüse und obendrauf die
beilage es ist auch nicht also man kann
sie damit machen
goldig und dann kann man ein wenn gäste
kommen richtig auf die hose machen oder
so lieber max ich probiere es erstmal
die ja wir warten ganz kurz
wir warten mal kurz zwei stunden hält er
auch gut war hat sich auch in der stunde
noch heiße spur
das war eines motto genau dass er eine
sport also wir warten jetzt gehörten
ernsthaft sie brot in scheiben
geschnitten ja schon gesehen dass du auf
der baustelle messe hat wenn wir keine
schaufel viele kinder wissen nämlich
schaufel auf der baustelle ein
schmerzhafter wird meine mama und mein
papa ihnen so ein ding gemacht ihr sohn
bernd wäre da noch das auge isst mit
sally zum schmecken draußen kalt oder
branche ist halt kein anlass ich mach's
das foto kann ich jetzt haben
nehmen wir doch noch ein bisschen drauf
machen eigentlich noch ein paar kräuter
aber com ist jetzt einfach probieren
also ich weiss export ab
reingucken hinweis über um sich gemacht
hat mit vollem mund spricht
das passt werden geschmack passt perfekt
ganz ehrlich mir ist noch nie gemacht
habe
dann probiert es mal also ehrlich jetzt
die petersilie zum beispiel noch trüb
war also wenn man sich die zeit nehmen
bis gott stehen ja alles auch gutmann
ist es wahr dass weihnachtsmarkt
gekommen mit dem sumpf trends
feststellen
ich finde es wirklich klasse wie der
mache ist unbedingt nach geschmeckt
gigant ihr habt da will bekommt ich
finde von der konsistenz ist perfekt
auch von der flüssigkeit her
falls jetzt sage ich mich ganz viel
weniger flüssigkeit oder etwas mehr und
gibt einfach mehr oder weniger mit dazu
aber ihr seht ihr wird es ungefähr bei
mir hier aussieht fiel auf als er dieses
rezept toll findet der wunsch noch was
sagen ja oder ja unsere richtig tolles
rezept und zwar diese ähnlichkeit mit
dem schmorbraten das verlinken verlinken
und mache aber den sportwagen aber
dieses fleisch nicht wirklich gemacht
und ich finde da könnte auch mal eine
schmorbraten machen mit diesen kraut
oder halt mal was ganz anderes und
faltig dieses rezept ganz toll findet
dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei auf
salehs - blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau für
euch murat lässt sich jetzt noch
schmecken wir machen noch ein paar fotos
und dann gibt's gleich essen also bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss jungs ran an
die arbeit und das essen
[Musik]